The Skywalker storyline comes to an end with
Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker, and that’s
too bad because there are plenty of stories
about the most famous family in the galaxy
far, far away.
From pirate adventures to clone craziness,
here are the best Skywalker stories we'll
never see in the movies.
Though there were rumors of a turn to the
Dark Side for Luke Skywalker leading up to
The Last Jedi, such a turn never took place.
Luke remained, even in his disillusioned state,
a bastion for good.
He got to save the day with his Force projection
duel against Kylo Ren, which allowed the Resistance
fighters to escape and proved that Luke remained
a true hero to his core.
But fans of the Expanded Universe know that
Luke was previously tempted by the Dark Side,
going so far as to become the apprentice to
the Emperor himself.
"I've got a bad feeling about this."
The storyline occurred in one of the first
Expanded Universe stories, the aptly named
Dark Empire.
This 1991 comic book from Dark Horse Comics
takes place just a handful of years after
Return of the Jedi, and it sees the Emperor
return from his presumed death at the end
of that film, with the explanation being that
he transferred his consciousness to a cloned
body at the moment of his death.
Luke, shocked to see him alive, agrees to
become his apprentice, with his plan being
to bring down the resurgent Empire from the
inside.
But the Dark Side corrupts Luke, and he loses
sight of his goal.
It takes a lightsaber fight against Leia for
him to snap out of it, and at that point,
he's finally able to defeat Palpatine.
Dark Luke would've been cool to see on the
big screen, but the window for this story
closed long ago.
In the official Star Wars sequel films, Luke
is not shown to have settled down.
As far as we know, he never had a serious
relationship, never married, and never had
children.
But in the Expanded Universe, Luke did all
of those things with a woman named Mara Jade.
Mara Jade was introduced in the 1991 novel
Heir to the Empire, the first installment
in Timothy Zahn's wildly popular Thrawn trilogy.
Mara is introduced as a smuggler who was previously
employed as the Emperor's Hand.
She's an extremely skilled user of the Dark
Side of the Force, and prior to the Emperor's
death, Mara was given the command to kill
Luke Skywalker.
She manages to kidnap Luke, but the two subsequently
become stranded in a harsh environment and
must work together to escape.
This event starts to bring the two together,
and though it takes several more novels, Luke
and Mara eventually fall in love and finally
get married in the 2000 Dark Horse comic Star
Wars Union.
But that's not the end of their story.
Luke and Mara also have a son together named
Ben Skywalker, whose first name appears to
have been recycled in the sequel trilogy as
Ben Solo, aka Kylo Ren.
Ben Skywalker grows up to become an accomplished
Jedi like his mom, but Mara doesn't live to
see it.
She's murdered by her nephew, Jacen Solo,
while on his way to becoming Darth Caedus.
Mara Jade wasn't the only character of significance
to be introduced in Zahn's Thrawn trilogy.
There was also Luuke Skywalker, with two U's,
an evil clone who made his debut in the conclusive
novel in the trilogy, The Last Command.
In the story, it's revealed that the clone
was created by the mad Jedi Master Jorus C'baoth.
C'baoth made the clone using Luke's severed
hand that Darth Vader cut off during their
battle on Cloud City in The Empire Strikes
Back, and Luuke even wielded Luke's original
lightsaber that was also lost in that battle.
C'baoth sics Luuke on Luke, and the two engage
in an intense lightsaber duel.
Given that Luuke is a genetic clone of Luke,
and that he's received expert Jedi training
from C'baoth, the two are a perfect match
for each other.
Their fight ends when resident badass Mara
Jade intervenes, using Leia's lightsaber to
slay both Luuke and Joruus C'baoth.
The real Luke comes to view Luuke as the fulfillment
of the vision he had on Dagobah in The Empire
Strikes Back, where he duels someone he thinks
is Darth Vader, only to realize it was himself.
Luuke Skywalker may not have featured heavily
in the Expanded Universe, but the idea of
an evil Luke clone whose creation came about
thanks to one of the most iconic scenes in
the franchise is undeniably awesome.
Not every Skywalker story in the Expanded
Universe revolved around Luke.
Leia also got some love in the EU, and she
got to do some pretty cool stuff in books
and comics that her on-screen counterpart
could only dream of.
And one of Leia's best stories that will never
make it to the big screen is the adventure
she took in Marvel Comics' Star Wars #73,
which was published roughly two months after
the release of Return of the Jedi in 1983.
The story, dubbed "Lahsbane" after the planet
on which it takes place, picks up not long
after the Battle of Endor.
Leia, Luke, Lando, Chewbacca, R2-D2, and C-3PO
are all still hanging out together, though
Han Solo had gone missing at the time, and
they've recently picked up a new ally: a pink-skinned,
female thief named Dani.
The gang heads to the planet Lahsbane to search
for the flight record of a Rebel pilot who'd
crashed there, and they learn the records
they need are located across a vast canyon.
Leia and Dani hatch a plan to secretly secure
the records themselves.
So under cover of night, the two women cross
the canyon...in a pair of hot air balloons.
Okay, yes, this story is ridiculous, but the
idea of Leia going on a female-only adventure
to prove her worth, even in a hot air balloon,
would've been fun to see on the silver screen.
If there's one thing Star Wars desperately
needs, it's a Jedi pirate.
And that's exactly what Cade Skywalker is.
Debuting in Dark Horse's Star Wars: Legacy
comics, Cade's story takes place many years
after the exploits of our traditional Star
Wars heroes.
Over 100 years after, in fact, as Cade is
the great-great-grandson of Luke Skywalker.
And since canon Luke had no children, that
means we'll never see a Cade Skywalker movie,
and that's a shame.
Cade Skywalker is downright awesome, there's
no getting around it.
The guy is basically a cross between Luke
and Han, with a little Boba Fett and Jack
Sparrow thrown in for good measure.
"You are, without doubt, the worst pirate
I've ever heard of."
"But you have heard of me."
He was raised a Jedi, but after seeing his
father murdered, he takes a different path
by operating in the seedier side of the galaxy.
He becomes a pirate and a bounty hunter, and
he has his own sweet ship with a loyal crew
of scallywags.
Cade eventually is confronted with his past
when he's discovered by the Sith Lord Darth
Krayt, who seeks him out due to his Skywalker
heritage.
Cade ends up reluctantly embracing his Jedi
roots and proves to be an extremely powerful
Force user, taking the fight to Krayt and
eventually killing him in combat.
Cade Skywalker's story is one of the EU's
most thrilling adventures, and it would give
Star Wars fans something they hadn't seen
in a movie before.
But alas, it seems like they never will.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.